ALRIGHT IT'S TIME FOR SOCK IT TO
ME.
LOOKING FOR A GIFT IDEA FOR THE
UNABASHED DRUNK IN YOUR LIFE?
SHUT UP, GRANDMA.
WELL HOW ABOUT A CHRISTMAS
STOCKING FILLED WITH BOOZE?
THERE IT IS.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
THE SANTA FLASK IS A BIG HIT
WITH EVERYONE EXCEPT FIRE
MARSHALS WHO GENERALLY
DISCOURAGE HOMEOWNERS FROM
HANGING A PLASTIC BAG FULL OF
FLAMMABLE LIQUID OVER AN OPEN
FIRE.
IT'S NOT A GOOD IDEA.
COMEDIANS GIVE ME OTHER TERRIBLE
IDEAS FOR THINGS TO PUT IN A
CHRISTMAS STOCKING.
60 SECONDS.
>> A FERAL CHILD.
>> A TURSTOCKING WHICH
IS A STOCKING PUT IN A STOCKING
STUFFED IN A STOCKING.
BRIAN POSEHN.
[BEEP].
POINTS.
TOM RHODES.
PHOTOS OF WHAT YOUR DAD
REALLY
DOES WHEN HE'S CAMPING WITH THE
GUYS.
>> Chris: POINTS.
[LAUGHING]
>> SECRET, HE'S BLOWING THE
GUYS.
Chris: BRIAN.
>> WET [BEEP]
Chris: RICK OVERTON.
>> OLIVE GARDEN GIFT
CERTIFICATES.